okay so let's now step a little bit away
from the specific results in the Senate
and in the house yesterday and think
about what this means for the future of
political movements including the
progressive movement which is the one I
care about normally it is a great time
for the opposition party the party not
in the white house to make progress when
you have a midterm after a presidential
election Trump and Republicans winning
in 2016 2018 just simply speaking
historically at the base level was
supposed to be was expected to be a good
mid term for Democrats however the
Senate was stacked against Democrats and
what I mean by that is you that you had
mostly Democrats defending seats and
Republicans not you had a lot of
Republican Senate seats that were just
not up this year so we already did the
detailed results but Dems won the house
lost the Senate and did gain control of
some new governorships which I'll
mention momentarily I am going to need
to talk some sense here to people on
both sides of this so-called blue wave
first of all on paper it really wasn't a
bad night for Democrats I know that for
a lot of people and I've been seeing the
tweets and the emails it didn't really
feel like it was a huge blue wave but
you've got to understand that the degree
to which it was stacked against
Democrats in the Senate Democrats with
way more seats to defend because
Republicans had 42 seats they almost had
a majority 42 out of 50 that weren't
even up for reelection they were totally
impervious to the blue wave since
they're simply not up for reelection
so yes Democrats were at a disadvantage
they've lost so far two seats net in the
Senate it might end up being three or
four we will see but Democrats did lose
some key races that they should have
been able to hold I mentioned the Heidi
Heitkamp disaster I get it it's the
Dakotas but it shouldn't have been as
lopsided as it was Claire McCaskill
another example I get it it's not the
most blue state Missouri but yet another
race that I believe was bungled
so that is extraordinarily concerning in
the House Democrats took control which
is great
barely though they needed 25 seats in
terms of a net gain they got depending
on where it'll be when when it's all
said and done is it 28 is it somewhere
in the low 30s it's not totally clear
the results in Florida were an absolute
disaster Andrew Gilliam losing there for
governor and Bill Nelson losing his seat
to Rick Scott in the Senate Florida
really big disaster for Democrats for
governorships it actually overall was a
really good night Democrats gained seven
governorships yesterday a net gain of
seven and Republicans had understandably
obviously a net loss of seven seats
that being said Stacey Abrams in Georgia
lost by just one point nine percent in
Georgia and there was voter suppression
there it's not actually clear to me that
she lost I got a couple calls yesterday
from people saying David should beta or
Roark contest the results in Texas I
don't think so I don't know that that
that's that beta or Roark lost because
of foul play in Georgia however where
you had the guy running the elections
Secretary of State Brian Kemp also
running as the Republican candidate for
governor and you had D registration
voter purges limited voting hours closed
polling places and in the end it's that
tight I do think that that's one that
needs to be looked into other
governorships that went the way of
Democrats main is a good one Michigan is
interesting Wisconsin is absolutely huge
where Scott Walker was defeated the guy
is disgusting
and it is so great to see him kicked out
Illinois Democrats took over the
governorship Kansas where nightmarish
Kris Kobach was defeated and we'll talk
about that a little more New Mexico and
Nevada saw governorships turn blue and
to me this is one of the biggest wins
from last night taking over the house is
very important
but taking over seven governorships is
so important because this is now seven
more states that could decide to follow
the Paris climate guidelines even if
Donald Trump pulls the United States out
of that agreement at the national level
this is seven more states that can
legalize marijuana as some states did
and restore voting rights to felons as
some states did or protect workers
rights which Scott Walker was not doing
in Wisconsin quite the opposite so that
is really really big and then the other
good news from yesterday is that if you
look at some specific states you see
that trumpism destroyed them and I want
to go back to Kansas the very red state
of Kansas where Donald Trump defeated
Hillary Clinton by 20 points in 2016 56
to 36 they have a Democrat who is going
to be governor defeating Trump crony
Kris Kobach Democrats in Kansas also
took one of four House seats from an
incumbent Republican and the person who
took it is Cherise David's which is huge
so in Kansas we've really seen how
bringing in this cut taxes and defund
social programs Sam Brownback right
winger ISM trumpism I don't know what
name you want to assign to it it led to
a definitive leftward move for Kansas
that is really great news and then also
good news are the ballot initiatives
Florida banned offshore drilling and
banned indoor vaping they restored
voting rights for felons Michigan
legalized marijuana by popular vote they
will be the tenth state to legalize
marijuana that's a clear trend
nationally and it's of course going to
continue the momentum continues to build
so listen the big picture is Democrats
took the house they didn't lose that
much in the Senate given how the races
favored Republicans they gained seven
governorships and a bunch of different
progressive ballot initiatives were
passed we won the popular vote in Senate
races by 12 million votes if you
count for two Democrats running in
California it's more like nine and a
half million votes and won the popular
vote overall if you look at the popular
vote across everything that happened
yesterday at the you know Governor's
House and Senate Democrats won the
popular vote by about eight percentage
points that's a blow out okay in
American politics that is a blow out by
any standards so Republicans do need to
be very worried there's all the positive
stuff okay that that we're getting out
of the way but here's where it starts to
get very very ugly
first of all does taking over the house
and plus seven governor's do a damn
thing about turning around the corporate
takeover of our political system and our
economy for the last 40 years the answer
is it doesn't do a thing and it's not
fair to expect that you would change
that with one election and I know that
we can say well there have been some
further leftists that won in the house
AOC in New York and some others that's
fine but only if they're able to achieve
change is that going to be a success
point so number one when I see the most
destructive and ignorant president in
decades single-handedly destroying
important geopolitical alliances around
the world making the United States look
like a joke insulting everyone making
economic policy with the total lack of
understanding of the consequences of
that policy and Democrats barely take
over the house I'm not just blaming
voters I'm not just blaming the
Democratic Party but we've got to get it
together okay if you care about what's
going on you have to vote and I know
voter turnout was up I know that it was
but it's got to be up more because
otherwise we're getting crushed in 2020
okay if there was ever a time to vote
wasn't it yesterday and meanwhile it's
great that Democrats took over the house
and gained seven seats in terms of
governor's but there is still no
cohesive Democratic strategy there is
this jumping
back and forth between playing
Republican light and being more
progressive being the sane centrist and
being Republican light in this constant
revolving door and most importantly
because it's okay to run races
differently based on where you're
running that's not the issue the issue
is that Democrats big-picture with
exceptions are not speaking to voters in
a way that truly resonates in terms of
why shouldn't they be afraid of losing
their status perceived or real if they
support Democrats that was one of the
top motivating factors for people voting
for Donald Trump the fear of losing the
status they either perceive they have
actually have or think maybe they would
have at some point in the future I'm not
saying that Democrats need to run the
exact way that Republicans run because
then we're just Republicans that's not
the point I'm making but if so many
people you have the right policies
within a reasonable sort of Overton
Window if you are a Democrat on many
issues but the voters aren't
understanding that and that's a
communication issue fundamentally and
then also they ran a lot of crappy
campaigns how can the Democratic Party
expect to win when this is what they're
able to do after two years of Trump and
some of the worst governance that we've
ever seen I am not one to defend Michael
a vanadis political approach I have my
problems with them but the one area
where I do agree with avenatti is that
he says we actually need to fight and
that doesn't mean compromise our
principles
it doesn't mean do things that we find
immoral but Trump will crush us in 2020
if we continue the waterfalls and Ginger
Snaps approach that too many but not all
Democrats take you can't be Republican
light you can't pretend that you don't
need to play the game period and if you
are disappointed and you should be to
some degree even though there were
victories last night we have a new
project we have two years now where the
goal is clear take over the white house
take over the Senate
expand control of the house and get a
majority in terms of governorships and
I'm going to be talking about that
shortly breaking news as predicted by
people connected to reality but denied
by trumpets it seems Donald Trump jr. is
now expecting to be indicted and quote
soon two days ago
Gabriel Sherman reported in Vanity Fair
that people at the White House are quote
very worried about Donald Trump jr.
Politico has now broken the news that
Donald Trump jr. has been privately
telling his own friends that he believes
he could be indicted and the big area of
I guess we would call it interest or
what would the subject matter of the
indictment be it looks like it could be
related to the fact that Donald Trump
jr. testified that he never under oath
that he never spoke to his father Donald
Trump about that infamous Trump Tower
meeting where Russians promised dirt on
Hillary Clinton did he lie about that if
he did that's bad
not only for Trump jr. but it's also
very bad for Trump's senior as well and
that could explain the rush to fire
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and to
put in place an interim replacement who
is very hostile to the Trump Russia
investigation because if Trump jr. lied
about not having spoken to Trump senior
about the meeting in advance that means
Trump senior knew about the meeting in
advance which immediately implicates
Donald Trump in potentially more crimes
and the Gabriel Sherman article says
that the White House insiders are
worried that Moeller would indeed be
able to prove prove that Donald Trump
jr. committed perjury and with perjury
very often being so difficult to prove
this would be absolutely massive and
then we've got to get to the meat of it
if indeed Donald Trump jr. lied under
oath why did he do it he obviously had
an attorney with him I'm sure that Don
juniors attorney said to him you're
gonna be under oath it's dangerous
legally speaking to lie to federal
investigators while under oath
it is a crime to do that and if it's
true as they claim that the Trump Tower
meeting with Russians didn't actually
produce anything of value to use against
Hillary Clinton why would Don Jr feel
the need to lie about it at all except
if the meeting did have follow-up and
Don jr. had told his father the reason
he would lie is that he'd be making the
call he'd rather chance lying to
investigators than admitting that yes
his father was a knowing part of the
effort to conspire with a foreign
country for the purposes of winning an
American election which exposes them to
all kinds of criminal charges and just a
reminder you remember this pat remember
when Steve Bannon said about Don junior
a year ago or so I think it was Jan late
December January when Steve bannon's
book came out quote they're going to
crack Don junior like an egg on national
TV this may be the beginning of trouble
for Don junior and correct me if I'm
wrong Pat you've been saying Don junior
is one of the top and IT possibilities
for a while oh yeah I'm not alone in
saying that too I think this would be an
absolute bombshell if Donald Trump jr.
was to be indicted and then who knows
what would happen from there I think
Trump would be in a position where he'd
have to pardon his own son maybe even
fire Robert Miller and the investigation
and we have a constitutional crisis on
our hands I don't think he'd be so
willing to do that for people like Paul
Manafort for Michael Flynn for Michael
Cohen but his own son I think he would
pull all the plugs pull out all the
stops and make sure that his sons not
gonna be locked up Don jr. he was
basically a waterboy he had nothing to
do with the campaign he had and has
nothing to do with the President of the
United States Donald Trump at all my
prediction is Trump won't literally say
he doesn't really think Don jr. was a
key part of the campaign that would
obviously be silly
but I actually do think that Trump is
going to throw Don Jr under the bus to
some degree and the reason why I think
that is that we've already learned that
when the initial news of the Trump Tower
eating first broke we learned that Trump
was reportedly absolutely furious with
Don Jr and nothing had even really
happened then like we didn't know at
that point how big that meeting and the
circumstances that led up to it we're
going to become so grab the popcorn this
is going to get extraordinary very very
soon Pat with the ranking of Donald
Trump's kids I think Don juniors
probably made like third like if this
happened to Ivanka Trump investigation
will be totally over Ivanka would be
pardoned if that ins a baron which I
don't foresee happening
maybe maybe trouble to get upset as well
but once you start getting down to
Donald Trump jr. - Eric - Tiffany Trump
maybe he doesn't care so much I actually
think the ranking for Trump would be
that Ivanka is his favorite particularly
you know all those times he's talked
about how amazing her body is it seems
he really really seems to think of her
as just the tops then I would say it's
Eric Trump then I would say it's Don Jr
and then sort of at the bottom
I think it's Tiffani and Baron who he
just doesn't even really seem to talk
about what a night
thanks to everybody who joined me on the
livestream by the way last night on the
David Pakman show YouTube channel
thousands and thousands of people coming
through and sending comments and a lot
of people signing up for memberships to
set up for the next two years because we
had results that I am going to go
through in detail yesterday we have
results from the house we have results
from the Senate we have results very
positive results for Democrats when it
comes to governor's races and we'll talk
about ballot initiatives just so much to
discuss let's start with the house then
do Senate and then we are going to kind
of sum up about the meaning of
everything that happened yesterday and
what's next and what is now possible so
in the house Democrats have won
Democrats took over control of the house
there are still numbers coming in so
it's not as of right now a hundred
percent clear exactly how many seats
Democrats picked up there are websites
right now that have it as plus 26 some
is plus 28 others that say it's going to
be somewhere in the 30s when it's all
said and done Democrats needed to gain
25 seats so at the conservative end of
those numbers not an overwhelming
victory
but taking over the house is taking over
the house gerrymandering is something
that when it comes to the house works
against Democrats and we have to see it
as a win even if it is one that is not
as big as we would have wanted some
notable races Alexandria
Acacio Cortes not surprisingly after
defeating the incumbent Democrat in the
Democratic primary got 78% of the vote
in New York's 14th district will become
the youngest member of the House ever at
29 actually is it ever
she'll be the youngest now I wonder i
believe it also is ever at 29 years old
sadly our friend JD Shelton who was
running in Iowa's fourth District
against Steve King who is one of the
most king is disgusting extreme white
nationalist neo-nazi associated members
of the House of Representatives JD
Shelton who I met in New Orleans at
Netroots nation interviewed him hung out
with him a little bit there such a good
guy
and would have been such an amazing
victory to take down Steve King
but sadly JD Scholten did not win ending
up just shy about 10,000 votes shy which
in that relatively in that particular
district worked out to fifty point four
to 47% about three point four percentage
points separating them you know valiant
effort what does that mean right it was
close is it better for it to have been
close than not maybe a because it
signals that even those red districts
could be turned blue
I sent JD a message and it's just a real
real disappointment good news from the
house congressman Russia also known as
California's Dana Rohrabacher he lost to
Democratic challenger Harley Ruda that
is fantastic news because it not only is
he an extremist Republican he's also one
of the most Russia co-opted members of
the House of Representatives and it is
fantastic that he is on his way out and
now as soon as Democrats are sworn in in
January it's time to get going and the
question is well what what do we get
number one investigations and I don't
mean just Trump we have been dealing
with in the Trump administration at
large not just the White House with one
of the most corrupt self-serving truth
ignoring groups of people that have
maybe ever made up an administration
David corn is already reporting that
House Democrats have started to put
together a list of areas of
investigation and subpoenas related to
the Trump administration the house has
dozens of committees and subcommittees
and they have some serious investigative
power and you are going to likely see
the Intelligence Committee revive the
Trump Russia investigation but in a
serious way not one where Republican
Devin Nunez
Trump's buddy is running back and forth
to the White House telling Trump exactly
what the committee is doing it will be
hopefully a non farcical investigation
you're going to see foreign affairs
hopefully look at the Trump Saudi
relationship and potential violations of
the emoluments clause with Saudi Arabia
but also with a whole bunch of other
countries and their attempts to
ingratiate themselves with Trump by
staying at his hotel in Washington DC
when they come in for official business
the Department of Homeland Security can
get right in the middle of the policy of
child separations that is being carried
out by the Trump administration at the
border armed services can investigate
whether Trump is violating the law by
using the military as law enforcement
when he sends them to the us-mexico
border to play cops because of the
immigrant caravan that is quickly
dwindling in size and very slowly
approaching the us-mexico border
Trump's cabinet members could and should
find themselves under investigation
you've got Wilbur Ross
ben Carson Ryan Zinke we've talked about
Betsy DeVos they've all been accused of
wrongdoing they all should be
investigated by the house if Donald
Trump found fake news an annoyance in
doing whatever the hell he wants I think
he doesn't yet know what it's like to
opposition house of representatives
investigating you in a serious manner
and then there are even more I mean
Oversight and Government Reform they've
got a very long list of things they want
to investigate Trump about this includes
why are they adding a citizenship
question to the census and what are the
motivations for doing that what about
the endless White House security
clearance scandals what about the Muslim
travel ban what about that ambush in
Nazaire that left four soldiers dead and
the Trump Foundation and Trump's
response to the puerto rican hurricane
use of primate even at private email by
the white house all of this stuff is now
on the table and then put all of that
aside then there's the House Judiciary
Committee and they have another list
which I'm not even going to get into
right now and what I absolutely believe
we need to demand of Democrats when they
take over control of the House of
Representatives they must investigate
the racially tinged voter purges that
have taken place in states all across
the country it's time to use the
subpoena power this is an attack on our
democracy there are attacks on our
democracy happening from foreign powers
and there are attacks on our democracy
for the benefit of the Republican Party
happening internally and then in
addition to the investigations can we
take control of the 2020 census back
because that has become a disaster under
Donald Trump can we take control or
prevent more outrageous tax reform bills
all of these possibilities are now on
the table because the Democratic Party
is taking over control of the House of
Representatives we will be speaking
about this a lot more later in the
program so late last week I had a few
sort of spare minutes in the craziness
of setting up the new studio and
tweaking things and I'll talk to you on
the bonus show about what's going on
with all that that I said let's see
what's happening on the news and I
kind of flipped around the cable news
networks to see what was going on I like
to see what's happening on Fox MSNBC and
and CNN and I turned to CNN and Jake
Tapper was filling in for Aaron Burr
Nets program and he was in the middle of
fact-checking Donald Trump and I don't
even remember what he was fact-checking
at the time it might have been something
related to the immigrant Caravan or it
might have been something related to
taxes I don't even really remember at
this point but it doesn't matter because
as I watched it it became clearer than
ever to me that fact-checking
Donald Trump is effectively a pointless
waste of time and and what I mean is the
following when CNN fact checks Trump who
cares in the sense that you either
already know that Trump lies all the
time and you care about that or you will
call CNN fake news because that has been
the sort of resounding repeated talking
point that we've seen from Trump and the
people around him about anybody who
tries to say that he is either saying
things that aren't true or attacking
people incorrectly or whatever else he
might be doing and even when you have
these other fact checkers or I guess we
could call them allied trackers correct
Trump but PolitiFact or the Washington
Post has like a lie tracker of some kind
Donald Trump has already preemptively
successfully primed the pump such that
people here fact-checking Oh Trump is
being fact-checked those are the lies
that's the fake news and this is in a
way brilliant this it's brilliant in how
effectively it has work and you've got
to really understand how bad this is a
focus on truth is no longer viable as a
strategy of enlightening people as to
what's going on politically and moving
the needle it doesn't matter so if you
said you know what I'm going to try to
step back from the left-right do a sort
of paradigm and in
of just criticizing things from a
left/right perspective I'm going to
focus just on truth I'm going to try to
figure out as closely as it's possible
to do this sort of epistemological II
what is true and what is not true that
narrative has been co-opted and and
maybe even better than co-opted it has
been debased
and made irrelevant where even just
saying I don't care about partisan
bickering I care about what we can
demonstrate with fact Trump has already
primed the pump so that his followers
and too many of those who say I'm not at
rumpus buts will not care about that
this is a massive debasement of the
discourse around American politics but
it's where we are and we still want to
win I think and that's where the
motivation for saying this comes from
that's where I'm motivated to say
fact-checking Trump in this way is a
pointless waste of time instead of
fact-checking there's going to need to
be again if the if the focus is winning
and there's a place for a focus on truth
but if the focus is winning there needs
to be a complete and total shift towards
how is our platform going to benefit
people who work how is it going to
benefit people in the lower middle class
how is it not a threat from the left
that you will lose status either real or
perceived if Democrats win because again
I'm not saying I believe that that's
actually a risk but the Trump is
perceived that he would protect them
from a loss of the status they either
believe they have actually have or hope
to have in the future and the trumpets
have pulled off a brilliant emotional
scam because it's no longer a sort of
rational basis on which they appeal to
voters
it's an emotional basis that they use to
appeal to voters it is their side that
claims the facts don't care about their
feelings you know that phrase that's
become popular their entire platform is
based on feeling and emotion it doesn't
matter
if the Pentagon said as I will tell you
later on in the show that the immigrant
Caravan is not a threat to the national
security of the United States if they
feel like it is and if they can be sold
a bill of goods that claims that it is
then that's all that matters
it doesn't matter if tax cuts for the
rich just allow the rich to hoard money
without helping the economy which is the
reality if it feels like the fair thing
to do is to let rich people keep all
their money or more of their money
because after all it's their money and
they create jobs if that feels like a
good argument it's going to work it
doesn't matter if the facts don't bear
it out and look at how bad they are and
how much they lie is totally accurate I
talked to my talk about that on the show
and others talked about it but it's not
allowed Democrats to win in a country
that keeps moving to the left more and
more people believe for example that the
government has a basic right to provide
a basic duty to provide everybody with
some basic level of health care more and
more people than ever believe that and
yet our elected officials keep moving to
the right depending on how you measure
it this is absurd and it is very easy
for the left to take this approach of
hold on a second if we just talk sense
to people and tell them what the facts
are we will win well go look at the
youtube comments on my channel go look
at the tweets that I get travel to
Indiana as I recently did or go to
politican and talk to these people and
you will realize if we just say the
truth will win out we're fighting an
unwinnable battle and showing people the
facts explaining to them that their
priorities are misguided and part of
this decade-long right-wing scam to
trick them into supporting the same
status quo that got us into this mess
just doesn't work okay and a ton of
people I know people will write in and
say David a lot of these people are just
dumb well dumb is sort of starting to
get ad hominem e but there are people
who lack the cognitive capacity to
understand a lot of these issues but
many others are just living their lives
they're trying to earn a living they
don't have time to dig deeper than
whatever slanted headlines they're
getting or whatever catchphrase Trump is
using and Vox calls this an epistemic
crisis the idea is
if one side rejects the epistemic
Authority of fact checking and of
knowable truth however you want to say
it the truth no longer matters and it no
longer speaks for itself
climate changes an example climate
science explains what's happening it's
overwhelming it's clear but so what
it hasn't changed the narrative among
much of the right at all and the more
facts they're presented with they either
ignore bury their head in the sand come
up with new anti scientific arguments
because once you question the authority
of the scientist which is what they've
done
once you question the value of the media
in general because you portray them as
the enemy of the people you are no
longer arguing on the merits of
arguments you're arguing in terms of
power fact-checking can work when you
have a society where authority and
trustworthiness and power depend on what
is demonstrable what you can prove and
what the facts are it doesn't right now
because we've fallen very very far so we
need something else I'm not sure what
but it has to start with voting tomorrow
because if Democrats recover some of the
Lost political capital tomorrow then
maybe we have something to talk about if
Democrats recover nothing in the
midterms I hate to tell you this but
it's going to be another two years of
exactly what we've had so people need to
vote if there is any way to sort of
explain to you how serious the rift with
some of our longtime allies has grown
and I've been mentioning this in my
election results coverage the conflict
between sort of normal Europe and the
nationalist right wing populist forces
that we've seen rise in the United
States under Trump and elsewhere have
now gotten to such a point that the
French president is saying there should
be a real European army created to
protect Europe against possible
abandonment by allies including the
United States in the event of military
conflict there is no possible way to
overstate the significance of one of our
biggest European allies saying that
things have changed to such a degree
that Europe must militarize together
against the possibility of conflicts
where the US may not be with Europe
nevermind possible conflict against the
United States Emmanuel macron said
yesterday or or the day before I believe
it was that quote we have to protect
ourselves with respect to China Russia
and even the United States of America
when I see president Trump announcing
that he's quitting a major disarmament
treaty which was formed after the 1980s
euro missile crisis that hit Europe who
is the main victim Europe and its
security peace in Europe is precarious
so this was actually interpreted two
different ways when news broke of it one
was Emmanuel macron is saying we need a
European Army in case France needs to
fight the United States I actually don't
think that's really the right
interpretation although it's it's of
course conceivable but the truth is that
the US and France are both NATO members
and were supposed supposed to be
participating in in shared defense the
idea of actual military conflict between
France and the United States even under
Trump is pretty unlikely
fortunately the more sort of realistic
interpretation is that France would be
worried that in the case of certain
conflicts the United States may not
actually participate in that shared
defense and honor the commitments that
they've made or may continue to further
back out of commitments that they've
made formally it's gonna be really
interesting to see how the American
right reacts to this because the normal
reaction from the right at the
micro-level and the and the country
level is how can we criticize anybody
for being prepared to defend themselves
they will apply this to countries in
terms of building nuclear arsenals or
obtaining huge weapons from massive you
know big time weapons from from the big
military industrial suppliers that we
talk about all the time they also apply
it to gun owners at the micro level will
they also apply it to Europe if your
reaction is doesn't matter we can take
Europe because we have a bigger military
you've already lost the thread you have
no concept of geopolitics you have no
concept of diplomacy you don't
understand
networked modern globalized world's now
let's be thorough there's another
interpretation of what and more
specifically why Emmanuel macron is
saying this and it has to do with marine
lepen marine lepen is the far-right
nationalist who now is part of the
nationalist rally party and if that
doesn't sound familiar it's because she
ran against McCrone when the party was
called the National Front they've
renamed now and they are the nationalist
rally party they have moved ahead of
Emanuel macrons party for the first time
the the far-right anti-eu parties in
France now have a combined 30 percent
support up from 25 percent so thinking
is it cynical is it just realistic if
you are Emmanuel macron and you are a
centrist and you see that you are
starting to lose to the far-right
nationalists in France one thing you
might say to appear tough on the
national stage and maybe head off some
of the attrition to the far-right that
you're seeing is hey you know what let's
build an army because what's more
nationalist than talking about building
armies now the far-right nationalists
may not really love the idea of it being
a European army because they are anti EU
and maybe want to see France go it alone
but but even in this case it doesn't
matter what the motivation is for
Emmanuel macron to say this and they
could be self-serving and sort of
cynical motivations the mere fact that a
centrist French leader is even willing
to say we need an army because we might
need to protect ourselves if the US
doesn't help us that in and of itself is
indicative of how far diplomatic
relations with France have fallen so
let's understand this very clearly to
sort of sum up the actual possibility of
armed conflict between France and the
United States remains extraordinarily
low the US and France as I mentioned our
NATO members
we are part of joint treaties and
agreements of all kinds but merely using
this as McCrone is doing as a defense or
justification for a European army that
is the monumental change in rhetoric and
thinking on this issue that we have been
predicting is exactly what we would see
as a result of how Trump handles himself
geopolitics have changed very quickly
under Donald Trump and in ways we sort
of predicted the the way this was going
to happen but it's still shocking to see
the French president say this and when
when we think about I mentioned earlier
you can build things over a long period
of time and destroy them very quickly
this is another example of that and some
of these alliances let's discuss
remember the Minutemen maybe this is a
good good way to start it some people in
our audience might be too young to
remember the Minutemen when george w
bush was president the Minutemen
organized themselves to extrajudicial et
extra judicially monitor the us-mexico
border what I mean by that is they would
they would show up at the border in
California and Arizona and I'm picturing
the map New Mexico and Texas on the
us-mexico border in the southwest of the
United States they would show up with
rifles and handguns and they were there
they said to help stop illegal border
crossings I know several Border Patrol
agents and they told me that they found
the Minutemen to be a gigantic and total
nuisance rather than any kind of help
there were like eight Fiasco's involving
these Minutemen I'm not going to go
through them here but long story short
the group ended up splintering into
several subgroups some of those groups
ended up conflicting with each other
some of them have still been patrolling
the border in smaller numbers I know you
know where the story is going we now
have the trumpets FoxNews fear-mongering
around the Latino middle Easterner
invasion that they believe is coming to
the us-mexico border so this has now
reactivated a lot of these different
gun-toting militia groups to head to the
border to I guess as they see it
protected
most of them realize that they are not
law enforcement so they can't work in a
law enforcement capacity since they're
just mostly dudes with guns but they are
saying we are going to be there to
observe and report what it is that we
see I want you to consider something I
told you in the last story that the
Pentagon advised the Trump
administration that the immigrant
Caravan itself is no invasion and poses
no threat but the military is warning
military commanders who will be down at
the border that the armed militias
turned vigilantes are actually what they
need to be aware of ok understand this
the military is being warned more about
the militias protecting the border than
the immigrants they're supposed to be
there to protect us against this is
terrifying and I know that I live in
Massachusetts right I'm sort of
insulated from a lot of this political
nonsense but this is a nightmare
you have xenophobic armed right-wingers
going to play army at the border
alongside border patrol and actual
military troops who shouldn't even be
there and maybe they're in violation of
the law because the military's not
supposed to be used to serve a law
enforcement function and what are they
even going to do for the weeks before
the caravan is even slated to arrive at
the border anyway because it's going to
be weeks and I am Telling You today
whatever the date is today the day
before the election mark my words if the
militias and the military and Border
Patrol are still there if and when the
caravan finally does arrive with as few
as a couple hundred people weeks or
months from now there will be violence
but it will not be because of the
immigrants because this is straight up
dark ages pre-enlightenment I mean I'm
haven't even sure what words to apply to
this this is retrograde behavior it's
disgusting and it is all ginned up in
this xenophobe
placating of the white the white
separatists and the white nationalists
that we have been talking about I hope
it doesn't get ugly and this is like I
go back to I get emails from people who
say David why do you want Trump to fail
why do you want the stock market to
crash why do you want the economy to be
bad I don't want any of those things
believe me if you looked at my mutual
fund account from October 2018 last
month it is by orders of magnitude the
worst month that my account has had ever
not necessarily in percentage but
certainly in dollars lost because over
time ideally you have more and more
money in there so nine percent is more
and more of a loss the last thing I want
is for the stock market to crash or for
Trump to fail or for North Korea to bomb
someone just so I can say look Trump
failed I don't want any of that stuff
and there's no evidence you can point to
that suggests that I do but when you see
these horribly misguided disastrous
decisions being made and you understand
it's obviously going to implode in their
faces to have Border Patrol and the
military and local law enforcement in
some cases and armed militias who are
often motivated by xenophobia more than
any sort of constitutional rights or
desires to maintain the rule of law and
then these immigrants show up it is a
recipe for disaster and my only hope is
that number one people don't hurt get
hurt invariably or end up hurting others
in irreversible or ways that that we
can't undo I think you know what I mean
but they've got to be held accountable
if that's what they do if you think that
this is gonna go differently I want to
hear from you make sure you follow the
show on Instagram a David Pakman show
you can follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman we've got behind the scenes
pictures of the studio and so much more
today's program is sponsored in part by
stamps.com which I've been using to mail
out the david pakman show calendars that
we do and a bunch of other stuff for
years at this point almost everything
now is
on demand so there's really no reason to
make all of those trips to the post
office whenever you have to mail a
letter or a package because you can get
it all on demand with stamps.com many of
you remember my stories about my
frequent trips to the post office to
mail stuff out to people in the audience
no more because now with stamps calm I
can access all those services from the
post office which are great services
from my desk 24/7 when it's convenient
for me buy and print official US postage
for any letter any package using your
own computer and printer mail carriers
will then pick it up click print email
and you're done we've been using it for
years and right now you can use the code
Pakman for a special offer including
fifty-five dollars in free postage a
free digital scale and a four week trial
don't wait stamps.com before you do
anything else click the radio microphone
very important click the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
type pachtman to get this deal
stamps.com radio microphone enter pakman
Attorney General Jeff Sessions has been
fired by Donald Trump protests already
planned all over the country for 5:00
p.m. local time this afternoon you might
be wondering why am I saying fired
because there are some reports that say
resigned there are other reports that
say forced out the bottom line is that
Donald Trump wasn't pleased with Jeff
Sessions dating all the way back to 2017
and ultimately it's up to Trump whether
Jeff Sessions remains Attorney General
or does not and there is every
indication from the reports that it was
Trump's decision to force Attorney
General Jeff Sessions out this has
everything to do with the Trump Russia
investigation and Robert Muller we will
talk about that the legal implications
as well as the interim or acting
replacement for Jeff Sessions where to
start I guess with what Donald Trump
said and not unexpected in many ways
this was a predictable firing even the
timing we could argue was predictable
and what Donald Trump said on Twitter
is that we are pleased to announce that
Matthew G Whittaker chief of staff to
Attorney General Jeff Sessions at the
Department of Justice will become our
new acting Attorney General of the
United States he will serve our country
well we thank Attorney General Jeff
Sessions for his service and wish him
well a permanent replacement will be
nominated at a later date the day after
the election because Trump knows or was
advised more likely that if he does it
before the midterms people might change
their votes realizing that this is part
of Donald Trump's plan to interfere with
robert molars investigation period
former FBI Special Agent Asha ranga
tweeting earlier today that even this
firing would potentially be relevant to
a case against Trump for objection
obstruction of justice and in fact right
before the tweets about the firing
Donald Trump tweeted about robert muller
as the last tweet before firing jeff
sessions and as usual referring to the
russia investigation as a witch-hunt so
it's as if we needed that to realize
that these issues are related and the
timing of the tweets the timing of the
firing everything about this is making
it very very clear and in general things
that you do hours after an election are
done that way specifically because you
identify that there's risk to doing it
that way before the election also
interesting acting Attorney General
we're going to talk about Matthew
Whitaker in a second but the idea of
putting in an acting Attorney General it
could be a long time until a permanent
Attorney General is put in and the
difficulty of that confirmation might
actually be part of Donald Trump's plan
to keep an acting Attorney General in
for a long time as long as possible
potentially depending on what happens
with Robert Moeller's Trump Russia probe
and part of why it might be difficult if
Trump's plan is to eventually put in
Matthew Whitaker specific
as Attorney General that could be made
difficult by the reality that Whittaker
literally wrote an op-ed for CNN arguing
against the molar investigation and
explaining how he would go about
shutting it down understand this and
we're showing the article that he wrote
some months ago to our television and
YouTube audience the guy who is taking
over for Jeff Sessions has publicly
stated how he would end the Moller
investigation which he believes goes too
far and he would do it basically by
starving it a funding which is the
common right-wing tactic we've seen them
try to do this with Obamacare we've seen
them try to take apart welfare programs
by simply starving them a funding and
that's exactly what Matthew Whitaker
says he would do so first and foremost
Pat this particular timing is very
obvious in terms of what it means and
then he's putting in not someone who
might be hostile to the investigation
but someone who is on the record as
being hostile to the investigation and
having a specific plan as to how he
would end it and chop chop - I don't
think they'd have too much time that
they can waste I think that's why sons
was fired immediately because it seems
from Muller's team that they were going
to come out with some of their findings
after the midterm elections maybe some
indictments are underway soon - like
Donald Trump jr. even Jared Kushner
Roger stone those names have been
mentioned so they have to do it all very
very quick and I think that the story's
going to end pretty soon you think that
the investigation in other words is
going to be coming to a close soon and
that thus part of I mean that that would
be an argument for the sort of futility
of even doing this because I've read a
few analyses which say if indeed Moeller
is getting ready to wrap this up then
changing Attorney General now to one
who's not recused on Russia potentially
wouldn't even really do that much
because we may already have all the
indictments prepared prepared already
and that that sort of is a question
there is both an urgency and also a
possible futility and it's important to
understand that even though sessions was
be
Lee GERD as we as per Trump as we've
heard many times partially for recusing
himself on all Russia related matters
after being caught lying about his own
contacts with Russia I will remind you
he was actually a loyal trumpet in
Trump's administration in a sense and
the the unfortunate reality if your
Trump is that Matthew Whitaker also
should recuse himself on anything
related to Trump Russia because he's
tied up in it with an op-ed explaining
how he would end an investigation that
he doesn't think should be going on in
the first place and in fact Nancy Pelosi
has already called for Matthew Whitaker
to replace him to recuse himself even
though Trump has been slamming sessions
time and time again sessions stuck with
it and it's not totally clear yet
whether Matthew Whitaker is going to be
an effective sort of roadblock for this
investigation a few reminders of the
long and troubled history between Donald
Trump and Jeff Sessions you will
remember the tweet where Donald Trump
said Attorney General Jeff Sessions has
taken a very weak position on Hillary
Clinton crimes where our emails and DNC
server and Intel leakers yes
grammatically confusing but publicly
criticizing his Attorney General not
something you normally see presidents do
and then maybe the first example of the
public strife between Trump and Jeff
Sessions was a tweet in February where
Donald Trump said why is a G Jeff
Sessions asking the Inspector General to
investigate potentially massive FISA
abuse will take forever has no
prosecutorial power and already late
with reports on Comey etc isn't the IG
an Obama guy why not use Justice
Department lawyers disgraceful and more
about the message sent by a president
criticizing the Rowan Attorney General
than the content because the content was
was mostly mostly nonsense it's also
important to consider the implications
of Jeff Sessions being fired because
sessions was in a way not just one of
the
loyal original trumpets but the last
remaining major link to establishment
republicanism and we've talked about
that before Pat and I think that's even
a point that you've made in the past
which is that sessions is not a sort of
Bannen Sarah Huckabee Sanders Kushner
type that he is an actual and he's also
not a military type he is a guy from the
establishment Republican base who was
there with Trump and now that link has
been severed as well yeah he's more of
an establishment type and how ironic is
that that left-wing groups they're going
to be protesting his firing all across
the country this is the guy that said
that good people don't smoke marijuana
that he used to like the KKK until he
found out that they smoked pot something
like that you know terrible record on
criminal justice reform and now because
politics makes strange bedfellows we're
all rallying to his support well I think
what's important to point out there is
that progressives who and sensible
Republicans who are going to protest
today because of this firing they're not
doing it because they agree with Jeff
Sessions politics and I think it that
it's actually refreshing in a way that
what is being protested here is an
attempt to get in the way of the normal
course of justice and to get in the way
of the checks and balances that we have
and it is it's it's interesting because
without defending anything that Jeff
Sessions stands for politically you can
still identify as all of the thousands
and thousands of protesters who will be
out today and I'm going to stop by the
protests in downtown Boston myself they
are out there because of what this
represents and by the way you mentioned
Pat the weed stuff Jeff sessions was one
of the bigger escalators of the war on
drugs and if there is any silver lining
politically in sessions firing it's that
maybe his firing will deflate some of
those Trump Justice Department plans to
resk elate the war on drugs which
actually would be great now on the
merits can Matthew Whitaker the acting
Attorney General as per trump replaces
replacing Jeff Sessions can he stop the
Moller investigation he can certainly
use different tactics to try and this is
where Democrats need to come down on
them if they do
they might be able to interfere with the
investigation before the new Congress is
inaugurated which will include a
democratically controlled house and that
also may be part of the urgency there's
a few different reads as to the
immediate timing right after the 2018
midterms
midterm elections and what's very clear
is that they aren't going to go quietly
this is going to be insane for years
this all very transparently relates to
the Russia probe which we're going to
get to next because Trump's lawyers
according to Politico have been advising
Donald Trump to wait a little bit before
firing Jeff Sessions hoping to get more
information from Muller about what is in
his findings and what is in his report
Donald Trump clearly has ignored that
advice and after the break were going to
talk about breaking news related to the
Russia probe Pat alluded to it Donald
Trump jr. now reportedly telling friends
that he believes an indictment is
imminent
soon expecting it send me your thoughts
on the firing of sessions get in touch
if you're joining one of these protests
around the country I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show